liebe Leute die Freiluftsaison bei
klicksum ist eröffnet das ein oder
andere Interview hatten wir ja schon
draußen auch Simon und Tilo goohan habe
ich hier im Mediapark im Grünen in Köln
getroffen ja und ich rede mit ihnen über
diese neue DVD von ihnen Geschichten aus
der Grotte und andere grottige
Geschichten mit einem grottigen coverer
grottigen Film Trash vom Feinsten
horrorrash ja und Comedy Street ist ja
auch angelaufen da geht ja einiges
schief darüber werden sie erzählen dass
ja son vor der Kamera Tilo hinter der
Kamera ja und noch eine Menge mehr seid
also
gespannt also man muss schon mal
feststellen Tilo hat sein Bruder Simon
überhaupt nicht im Griff der Mann ist
einfach weggelaufen das ist ja super ja
kommt er wieder oder da siehst du die
beiden der eine im Hellen
Hemd das ist der Simon mit dem großen
raumgreifenden Schritt dahinter ist sein
Bruder Tilo der übgens ein paar Jahre
älter ist ich glaube 5
Jahre guck
halli hallo hallo Tag Simon hallo chr
was lange wert wir endlich gut hallo
Mensch dazu muss man sagen ich habe ihn
schon des öfteren genervt jahrelang um
dich zu bekommen aber hat er dir
wahrscheinlich nie ausgerichtet das ist
nicht so leicht mich zu
kriegen das haben schon andere versucht
okay ich mache immer wenn ich nichts zu
sagen hab alsoich nichts hab weiß ich
auch nicht Interview machen soll dann
ist ja dann hört man ja auch nichts weil
ich do doch das kriegt man bei uns immer
was geredetimmer so Momente wo wo man
sich anschweigt das ist ja unschön das
ist nee das ist schön das kann sehr
spannend
sein habt ihr eentlich mal reingeguckt
in kckum ich Ken das wer kennt die erste
Frage ich kenne die erste Frage ich k
die erste Frage wie ist die Lage genau
wie ist die Lage laufen wir schon
natürlich laufen wir schon ach steil hat
man in der Seen Klasse bei uns gesagt
steil steil ehrlich ist das steil vom
vom fein das sagt man in wie heißt das
noch mal Niehorst steil oder vom
Feinsten beides beides okay wo sagt man
das in nie wie heißt noch mal der Ort
woherst nie also das ist Gütersloh
eigentlich so ein Ortsnamen den man sich
nicht merken kann aber wahrscheinlich
man könnte sagen nee das ist einfach ein
Landstrich der Namen kriegen muss weil
ja es gibt ja
irgendwie wie soll man sagen eine
eingezeichnete Grenze geographisch und
da muss man ja dem auch einen Namen
gegeben oder ja so ist das okay und da
komm im Kreis GÜ Mö m schön wir haben
sind doch mit E ganz
gutmen hab glücklich
Kind das Ortsschild wir immer geklaut
immer
g und zw hät bei euch in den Buden ich
hab nein es war schon weg wir wollten
aber es war schon wego beim Thema sind
ich bin durch den Süden gefahren jetzt
beruflich vorgestern und bin durch
flaumenloch
gekommen aber man kann auch durch Spalt
oder durch feucht fahren immer wieder
ein Thema und auch durch fickmühlen ne
ja stimmt gibt es das ist oben Hamburg
gibt's auch glaube ich oder ist
ein Nachname das auch aber ich glaube
das gibt's auch aber fürü auf jeden Fall
schön ja das ist ja schon mal ein guter
Einstieg wir wollenomchen Niveau direkt
gesettelt Promo machen weil Niveau schon
sind wir brauchen jetzt nicht zu
verheimlichen ach ihr habt ja nein Ihr
seid hergekommen weil ihr habt was
sensationelles und zwar es man kann es
bezeichnen als euer Lebens ist das
korrekt ja unser frühes Lebenswerk
vielleicht er der letzte aber das ist
noch in den warte mal der letzte Film
ist aber auch a bis in die ja fast bis
in die Gegenwart die letzten Jahre also
die letzten Eintragungen sagen wir in
dies Lebenswerk pletschern so in den
letzten Jahren dahin fakt ist im letzten
jahrzehn war nicht richtig viel los okay
aber ihr habt letztlich das sind die
Wurzeln dessen was er heute
professionell macht das ist richtig so
ist das entstanden das heißt wenn man
euer Werk heute verstehen will dann muss
man das eigentlich gesehen haben das
muss man gesehen haben ja um ehrlich zu
sein mir war es immer so ein bisschen
peinlich aber jetzt wenn es fertig ist
ist ist schön auch für mich aber viele
viele Sachen sind auch einfach peinlich
aber das hat ja den gewissen reit das
macht ja auch den Reiz aus also sie
wirken nicht so sie wirken nicht nur
peinlich sondern sie sind es auch aber
es ist ja auch schön dann aber Moment
wir haben die allerpeinlichsten davon
auch in ein spezielles Menü gepackt okay
und das heißt deleted movies ah das ist
schön und das ist auch nur auf der Bonus
DVD und die Filme S
die Bonus DVD ist glaube ich DVD 2 und
hier guck mal da deleted movies die
Filme sind die vier Filme sind alle
totale Scheiße furchtbar ja aber wir
dachten uns entweder oder ja okay diese
DVDs sind auch immer so ein bisschen so
persönliche Archive dass wir die selber
die Filme in ein guten Qualität
sozusagen für die Ewigkeit okay
archivieren und da dachten wir da gönen
auch die allerschlechtesten zu deswegen
sind es auch 525 Minuten geworden das
hab alles re das ist wirklich inklusive
dann Musik und Jaud aber kommlich sogar
ein Interview von Center TV in einer
erqucklichen läe ist dabei ne da weißt
du Bescheid ne was wo ist denn das hier
irgendwo war das ja ja ist ja auf jeden
Fall drauf ja ja ja 37 Minuten Hammer
ist einfach die ganze Sendung halt ne
okay und euch ist nichts peinlich muss
ich daraus
feststellen es hilft nichts mit dem also
ich glaube dass viele manche Sachen als
peinlich betrachten die wir gar nicht
peinlich finden und umgekehrt das ist es
eben oft ist es ja so dass B irgendwie
den großen Hit haben und der ist den
furchtbar peinlich aber alle finden ih
gut und umgekehrt ne das ist unser
bester Song den find alle scheiße also
die Geschmäcker sind so vielfältig da
kann man nichts drauf geben es ist
subjektiv mit dem peinlich und häufig
ist das ja auch die humorgrenze die ist
nur bei jedem anders also von daher ist
das schwierig ja gut es gibt ja auch so
Phänomene wie moneyby der einen
unglaublichen Erfolg mit etwas hat wo
die einen sagen oh Gott mein Gott ja
dreh den Zweck auf und wo du ich find
moneyby gut aber ich finde noch besser
wobei das sind Künstler das darf ne
Künstler so HG ich t heute gehe ich tot
kennst du noch nicht ne nee nee Ken ich
noch nicht ein Künstlerkollektiv aus
Hamburg und der größte Hit ist
Hauptschule okay so tut DJ tut and
chamun ja tut and chamun ist man checkt
das nicht sind wohl mehrere DJs
und es gibt auch noch tut Jamon ist
glaube ich ein Lied das ist wo der auf
dieser mofer sitzt und immer sagt ja ja
das kennst du
Hauptschule in der Schule sch was kommt
raus g ja auch ein Günter ja auch in der
Disco kennst du das das kenne ich ja
das sensationell aber sind Künstler wenn
man Interviews sieht dann also die
distanzieren sich von der Marke Trash
aber die aber ich hätte jetzt gesagt das
ist so ein eigenes Universum da kennt
ihr euch aus und also wir gucken gerne
YouTube und informieren uns gerne und
bilden uns weiter wenn es früher Youtube
gegeben hätte vor 20 Jahren dann werden
wir heute viel berühmter als wir es
jetzt sind also ich ich erlich
ja also das sind
Filme die man halt mit den Möglichkeiten
die man damals hatte machen konnte ne
also wir haben damals alles ausgeschöpft
so fing das an hinterher hatte man mehr
Möglichkeiten aber natürlich auch mehr
Einschränkung oder so ist das
fernsehenarbeit ja genau also so
ist das ja wenn man ein Publikum hat da
muss man so ein bisschen gucken ne
welche Richtung geht man da sind wir
manchmal rausgegangen ohne irgendeinen
Plan ohne irgendwas vorher zu wissen und
haben Filme komplett da so hin
improvisiert inklusive Dramaturgie ja
aber es ging um die Kostüme eigentlich
ne wir haben Kostüme angezogen und um
die Special Effekts habe ich den
Eindruck oder bei den längerfristig
gepanten da auch schon aber oft haben
wir auch einfach Kostüme angezogen und
der Rest ist dann halt spontan
entstanden um die Kostüme drumrum weil
man sah aus wie ein Kop dann war
derjenige ein Kop das aber zufällig weil
der sich als erstes die Hose genommen
hatte die ein Kopf
anhat es war war Verkleidungskiste also
so die Kinder die sich verkleiden nur
das dann gefilmt aber trotzdem ohne auch
ohne youtube hat das zu der Karriere
geführt die ihr beide gemacht hab in ja
in eig würdet ihr sagen in eine Richtung
oder warte wir müssen noch einmal sagen
Geschichten aus der Grotte heißt das hab
haben wir immer noch nicht gesagt
Geschichten aus der Grotte gibt der
ganzen DVD den
Titel und das weil das bezieht alle
Kurzfilme mit ein es gibt aber einen
Hauptfilm und der heißt tatsächlich
Geschichten aus der Grotte und der geht
24 Minuten das wiederum ist aber ein
Episodenfilm mit ramenhandlung Gesichten
aus der Grotte ein eigenständiger Film
und gar nicht mal so also als als wir
damals Filme gemacht haben haben das
noch nicht so viele gemacht wie jetzt
weil die Möglichkeiten noch nicht da
waren also insofern kann man sagen man
stolz zurückblicken sagen wir waren auch
ein bisschen wie die anderen Filmer
damals unserer Zeit voraus ne weil die
Mittel waren so ein bisschen na ja und
wir haben trotzdem gemacht ja und ja
aber das das war's dann auch schon und
wie ist ich meine das haben ja auch
trotzdem einige gemacht
aber wie seid ihr dann ohne dass es SAS
wie YouTube gab
wie der ja und auch Filmfestivals noch
wo man dann eine Aufmerksamkeit bekommen
hatte weil es eben so ein so so ein mega
Verteiler wie YouTube noch nicht gab ne
so muss man das sagen da war dann noch
so eine Szene irgendwie da die war so
ein bisschen überschaubar und da haben
wir das da haben wir dann auch gutes
Feedback bekommen und deswegen
weitergemacht ne heutzutage man würde
man sagen 20 Klicks ich drehe nie wieder
was und wir ja als wenn man so ein so
ein Film hatte und der hat dann Lacher
gehabt dann war doch alles gut so dann
hat man halt irgendwie weitergemacht
oder genau es gab dann Draht über jemand
den ich auch vom Filmfestival kannte
also da kommt das dann wieder zum Tragen
und der hat gesagt die machen jetzt Viva
2 und es gibt eine Sendung da sollen
Kurzfilme gezeigt werden und und ihr
habt doch welche gemacht kannst du die
kannst du nicht mal welche schicken und
dann habe ich so unsere meiner Meinung
nach besten Filme hingeschickt und dann
ging ru sind sie dann gelandet sind dann
gelandet und da lief das in der Sendung
lange bevor Simon dann bei Viva 2
angefangen hat aber es war dann so dass
Simon ja Bock hatte nach Köln zu gehen
und dann gab es diese Anknüpfung so das
ist der Typ dessen Filme wir schon
gezeigt haben ne das kam das hatte dem
hat dem Nils gut gefallen und dann bin
ich da als Praktikant gelandet genau du
warst auch einer der vielen Praktikanten
die im Bild waren ich bin noch lange
gemacht worden von ihm in der Kulisse
aber es war irgendwie auch lustig eine
Zeit lang warst du eigentlich mehr oder
weniger so der einzig Praktikant so ne
ich war da so ein bisschen so ein so ein
zeitkick dann von ihm äh und Praktikant
ja genau ähm man kennt ja Nils Ruf
versteht ihr euch noch oder habt ihr
keinen Kontakt mehr wir haben noch
Kontakt ja nicht so oft einmal im Jahr
vielleicht und ich war auch letztens bei
ihm in der Webshow und
ja aber drei min sein Portal gibt's
leider bald nicht mehr ne gibt es nichtr
nein schalten Sie jetzt ab
oh ich f Lucki gut ja war lustig mit
Slayer hast du das gesehen habe ich
nicht geguckt aber ja gut gut ja okay ja
D mit dem will ich auch schon seit
ewigen Zeiten Interview machen das ist
aber schwierig er ist schwierig zu
händeln ich glaube er ist terminmäßig
ein bisschen auch wir haben schon
Aufsager gemacht alles prima aber
schwierig ja ja ja ja ja alles schwierig
ihr habt schon Aufsager gemacht
demnächst be uns in der Sendung ja aber
wir haben noch nicht ausgestrahlt weil
wir uns noch nicht so geeinigt haben
darauf wie das Interview dann und wo und
überhaupt und ist er wollte damals auch
bei Dance Sensation mitspielen erst ne
ja ja das war dann auch organisatorisch
eher schwer das stimmt das hat sich
vermutlich nicht er er ja er hat weiter
in seinen Lebensstil den er immer hatte
und er ist sich auf seine Art auf jeden
Fall treu geblieben und ich muss sagen
ich schätze ihn sehr okay immer noch
nach all den nach gleichermaßen nach all
den Jahren und ich habe auch einige
Sachen bei ihm gelernt tatsächlich ja
die Sachen die man nicht machen sollte
sa ja gut aber weil er sie macht ja ja
ich habe die damals diese ganzen
Geschichten alle ziemlich aus nächster
Nähe mitbekommen und die waren auch
nicht alle so gerecht ihm gegenüber
aber er ist auch kein Kind von
Traurigkeit wie wir wissen man trifft
sich irgendwo da in der Mitte und naja
passt schon ja okay und als Praktikant
das hat hat der trotzdem Spaß gemacht
weil manchmal denke ich so boah sow all
diese Praktikanten die es da gab es ist
ja eigentlich so ein undankbarer Job
weil man ja eigentlich der haut drauf
Typ ist ich war absolut der haud drauf
Typ im Prinzip so ein Vorgänger vom
bekannten showpraktikanten der SP no und
aber ich meine wenn man so wenn man das
im Kopf einfach differenzieren kann ne
also ich war ja total Fan von seinem
Humor und ja gut ich wurde vorgeführt
aber das ist dann das Absurde selbst
wenn man vorgeführt wurde war man ja
dann in güterslow wenn man am Wochenende
wieder da war so ein bisschen der Held
weil man ja in der Glotze war also es
ist völlig schit so eigentlich aber hat
doch eigene Einspielfilmchen dann
gedreht ich würde gerne den und den
Einspielfilm drehen hat vorgeschlagen ja
dann mach halt egal ich glaub es g noch
nicht mE eine Abnahme ne jeder konnte
machen ja also es war Zuckerbrot und
Peitsche okay aber es war damals schon
ein bisschen wie es heute auf youtube
ist aber wie es heute im Fernsehen
eigentlich nicht mehr ist richtigtig
eigentlich war via Z ein bisschen
Youtube ne es lief irgendwie mittags
liefen dann Death Metal Videos und oder
Independent oder Marilyn Manson mit
horrormaske war alles egal so ne und und
es gab Formate Z bot mit Figuren und
also eine Menge kreative Vögel die
irgendwie aus dem Sender her vorgegangen
sind zu denen wir heute noch Kontakte ja
also war eine kreativ obwohl ich jetzt
ja nicht direkt involviert war aber
indirekt aber Kerz Stefan KZ der
damalige Programmdirektor der hat damals
dann durchgedrückt das Captain kosmotik
läuft das stimmt natürlich und Katz und
Nils waren das das waren Katz und Nils
Nils wollte das gerne auch in seiner
Sendung haben und das war schon enormer
Schub damals da haben wir wurde Captain
kosmotic in so eine Serie zer 90 Minuten
Film von uns und hab genau immer so dre
Minter jeden Tag und das lief dann echt
über Monate als 26 teilige Serie
und das haben echt viele gesehen ne und
dann lief noch mal zu Weihnachten Block
also als ein Film richtig mit
Werbeunterbrechung der einzige Film den
ich aufgenommen hab mit
Werbeunterbrechung weiß du so und
zwischendurch immer so eine Werbung von
so diesen CDs mit so sphärischer Musik
so MS hieß die CD aber seitdem habt ihr
arbeitet ihr zusammen macht Comedy
Street du drehst auch bei Elton vs Simon
also letztlich hat seid ihr seitd dem
auch weiterhin unzertrennbar oder habt
euch nie
getrennt hat immer mal wieder
zusammengefunden nicht bei jedem Projekt
aber bei Comedy streed das
kontinuierlich ja bis heute und das
geht ja das geht ja warum die Frage ist
warum nicht oder sag mal du hast gerade
schwitzbübisch gelächelt nee also es ist
ja auch immer so ein bisschen
unterschiedlich ne wir machen auch
getrennt voneinander Sachen so ne und
mal ist Tilo der Macher bei unseren Film
ist er natürlich immer der der Macher
mal jetzt bei Comedy Street ist ja Tilo
das Auge die versteckte Kamera so ne
dann arbeite ich inhaltlich auch dann
gibt's ja noch ein Regisseur und so und
so sind die Konstellationen immer
unterschiedlich und es ist
manchmal so dass wir Sachen richtig so
zusammen machen so aber nicht das ganze
Jahr über ne also manchmal sind wir auch
einfach quasi so Kollegen und klar wir
sind super eingespielt und deswegen ist
das auch auch top aber wir sind nicht in
der Position dass wir so sind sondern es
ist Tilo sagt ja geh mal dre dre ich bin
dann für too halt der darstell
über so und dann machst du das auch ja
na klar weil es gibt Leute S 3 m rüber
ich will aber nicht 3 me rüber wir
hatten über so ein Kollegen vorhin
gesprochen ja ja gut ja ja eine andere
Anekdote ist dass er mit einem blauen
Shirt die zum Blu Screen Dreh kam habe
ich auch schon mal
gehört was
werschein ich gehört aber muss man auch
sagen ist lustig ist auch Entertainment
wenn man immer we weißt du immer brav zu
sein man muss sich diese Leute
irgendwie in Ehren halten weißt du diese
weil diese braven Menschen die sind ja
die gibt es ja aber die sind ja auch
weißt ich habe da auch mal schlechtes
Gewissen weil ich habe so bin immer so
normal und so und ich biete da ja auch
kein Entertainment so aber du bist ja
nicht immer brav ja aber ich muss doch
mal muss doch auch mal mit mit mit
zugeguckstter Nase im Ferrari V Baum
fahren so das ist doch lustig und mus
einfach auch diese Leute geben die so so
irre sind so das ist ja noch das
Entertainment hinter den Kulissen und
deswegen deswegen berer Z ja ich will ja
gut das sind jetzt natürlich die großen
Namen aber man kann da ja auch woanders
anfangen und und die Leute muss man klar
die werden immer verurteilt aber man
muss sich auch irgendwie so wie gesagt
in Ehren halten weil das ist doch auch
auch was ja wie sagt man das bewegt
einen doch hätte mehr machen können im
Dschungelcamp weil er ist eigentlich
einer von dieser alten
Haudegen ne der hätte eigentlich
irgendwas hätte ma kaputt machen müssen
im Dschungel ke Z aber jetzt noch mal zu
dem ich habe nämlich letztlich hatte ich
ein lustiges Thema mit einem anderen
Youtuber der sehr erfolgreich ist und
sagte wieso das und das darf ich nicht
sagen kann ich sagen ich bin doch ein
Vorbild und das hat mich verblüfft dass
das doch in deren Köpfen so drin ister
wahrscheinlich vielleicht keine Ahnung
ja klickst du ja die großen Zahlen habt
ihr ja mit den Rappern ja
natürlich auch zu einem irgendwie
geäußert und dann uh dann geht das in
die Luft ne so und so uh weiß ich nicht
genau Bushido war ja okay genau nein
nein das ist aber das ist die Frage ich
finde es ja gerade so es ist natürlich
so man man hat gewisse Verpflichtung man
kann jetzt nicht jemand umbringen vor
Lauf der Kamera ist ein bisschen blöd
ist auch kontraproduktiv was die eigene
Karriere betrifft aber was kann man
machen was kann man nicht machen in wie
gesagt ist man Vorbild wie weit ist man
nicht Vorbild als jemand der im
Rampenlicht steht und genau deswegen ist
der Beruf so schwierig und deswegen
kriegt das nicht jeder sofort hin weißt
du weil du brauchst ja trotzdem deine
Aufmerksamkeit du musst aber diese Dinge
berücksichtigen nun wenn man zu brav ist
ist man langweilig und und andersrum das
gleich haben wir bei El V Simon welchen
Wettbewerb machen wir wir dürfen ja
keine Gesetze brechen da besteht ja
nicht der Gag so ne weil weil
letztenendes kommt dann die Polizei und
na man darf ja keine Gesetze man muss
aber ein Tabu brechen aber welches Tabu
wird was was war für dich das Schlimmste
oder wo du dich überwinden musstest ähm
jedes Mal eigentlich immer ähm immer ist
immer Überwindung aber macht am Anfang
hat man immer so voll Bock so ja ist das
abgefahren wer kann mehr essen voll geil
ich fress voll viel aber wenn man mit
drin ist und nach 20 Minuten ist einem
schlecht so jetzt habe ich überhaupt
kein Bock mehr auch bitte lass den
Wettbewerb zu Ende sein und dann geht's
noch drei Tage und du kaufst hggen das
und doppelten Cheeseburger so na ja äh
immer unterschiedlich aber ja das ist so
ein bisschen die Schwierigkeit wenn man
in halte kreiert viele sagen so e geil
ich hätte deinen Job Mann durch die
Gegend gehen und Scheiße bauen ja aber
so einf das ist es halt nicht weil weil
weißt du wenn ich weiß du ich muss auch
immer nett sein zu den Leuten wenn ich
einen anpöble dann sagt die Oma
Schneider sagt jetzt rufe ich die
Polizei und dann kommt die grüne Minner
dann nehmen die mich mit weißt du haben
wir auch keinen Bock drauf dass
irgendeiner aus dem Fernsehen da
irgendwelche Leute anpöbel nee ja da
gibt jetzt auch einen sehr schönen
Ausschnitt wieder von einem Kollegen der
bis zur jüngster Zeit noch eine Talkshow
in Sat 1 hatte aber jetzt nicht mehr und
Harald Schmidt hat etwas was bisher
nicht ausgestrahlt worden ist aus dem
giftschank geholt Late Night Late Night
keine Talkshow Late Night
wahrscheinlichentschuldigung Late Night
Late Night ich glaube ich weiß wen du
meinst na ja J auf das Brutalste Kinder
verarscht oh wow wow ja ja schwierig
schwierig ja das ist immer so ein so ein
Schl aber für uns ist es Entertainment
dass die beiden jetzt sich so bekriegen
ja das hat doch ein wahnsinns
Unterhaltungswert oder also ich
verurteile gar nicht diesen Klip mit dem
Kind ich verurteile das alles gar nicht
find aber hervorragend diese dieses
Entertainment was zustande kommt durch
diesen Zwist das ist eigentlich
unbezahlbar weil gibt's in der
Konstellation das könnte jetzt so wenn
Elten und Simon sich sowas jetzt
wirklich geben W aber wird
wahrscheinlich gar keiner glauben wür
alle sagen Wettbewerb wer macht sich
unbeliebter oder so aber bei den beiden
seri also zumindest der eine ja sehr
seriöse Moderator da so Wahnsinn e was
macht ne was haut er den in den Socken
ne Ahnung ich bin immer noch nicht
sicher ob das so ist oder ob die sich
gegenseitig befruchten durch dieses
mediale sch das war schon eine das war
aber Schlachten ich ich würde mich nicht
wundern wenn die sich so simsen so boah
du Sack jetzt kriegst du wieder einen
rein und sich da drüber kaputt lachen
aber wahrscheinlich zu kurz gedacht ne
da sind halt überall Fallen aufgestellt
also ich meine gerade auch bei
versteckter Kamera musst du auch immer
an die Grenzen gehen und ich bin halt
immer so der sensible dann haben wir
noch unseren Regisseur Jens holzgrbe der
ist schon immer so ein bisschen der
pusherhr so aber diese Momente wenn du
dann die Grenze überschritten hast das
darfst Du ja nicht du musst ja mit der
Grenze spielen aber wenn du es
überschritten hast die ist ja furchtbar
unangenehm dann warst du unhöflich der
GCK hat nicht funktioniert oder du warst
irgendwie Zend die Leute sind
abgeteturnt dann dann es ist furchtbar
unangenehm aber natürlich kommt das vor
wenn du mit wenn du die Grenze immer im
Auge hast so ne dann kommt das auch mal
vor dass du ne oder weil man sich halt
immer auch ein bisschen ausprobieren
muss bis man weiß wie Figur und so
funktionieren ne weiß du noch wir hat
einmal z.B die Geschichte aber die ist
ein bisschen länger soll ich sie
erzählen ich weiß nicht gerne die lang
die kurz Version wir hatten einen
Stuntman und der hat sich zum Opper
verkleidet ah okay und dann haben wir
den Gag gemacht der macht das ist jetzt
in der aktuellen Staffel ab 11 juni
genau D macht der der der Oper macht
macht immer so Stan das ist ganz lustig
weil der geh mit so einer Gehhilfe und
macht dann irgendwie so ein salte oder
so das ist schon das schon lustig und
dann Dach wir ja okay ihr könnt ja mal
die Treppe runterfliegen ist kein GCK
wenn ihr die Treppe runterfliegt ist
kein Gag wahnsinnig schlechtes Make-up
sehen die Leute so schnell nicht er
fällt die Treppe runter und alle denken
da fällt ein alter Mann die Treppe
runter ganz unangenehme Situation und
alle Rennen zur Hilfe eilen zur Hilfe
und helfen und oh wir haben uns
entschuldigtchuldigung der G ist schief
gegangen ja du kriegst es nicht gedreht
man kriegt es nicht gedreht aber die
Leute haben es verstanden wir haben
immer ein gutes Standing zwei sind uns
hinterher gekommen und haben es die
Hölle heiß gemacht und haben gesagt das
geht nicht Mar Lehrer Ehepaar riesen
Stress gehabt haben wir uns den Klip zu
Hause guckt ist uns aufgefallen das
waren die zwei die nicht geholfen
haben so sind die Leute so wegen
Zivilcourage offensichtlich also der
vermeintlich proletige Typ der es nicht
war aber erstmal auf den ersten Blick so
aussah ist hingegangen und hat dem Opa
geholfen und war völlig korrekt wir
haben den aufgeklärt und er hat gesagt
könnt ihr senden alles wunderbar und der
Sandalenträger der 68er ökolehrer der ja
immer so viel auf Zivilcourage hält der
hat nicht geholfen der der hat da so
gesessen und
geguckt und der ist uns hinterher
gerannt und wir glauben der hat sich so
schrecklich aufgergt weil er eben sich
erppt gefühlt hat weil er nicht geholfen
hat und weil der den er wahrscheinlich
verurteilt hätte sofort hingegangen ist
der Muskelmann weißt der aus dem McFit
das heißt schlimm oder die Menschen
Christoph oder ist schlimm ne odal sch
es ist nicht alles so einfach wie man
sich das vorstellt nee nee die Guten
sind nicht immer gut und die schlechten
sind nicht immer schlecht so ist es so
ist es war definitiv so bist du da
manchmal froh nicht in seine Haut zu
stecken frst du nichtich ob ich das
Problem ist dass gerade bei der letzten
Staffel ich übelst angegangen wurde
zweimal einmal auch Düsseldorf Altstadt
Simon macht ein GCK in im Kiosk geht weg
weil der G zu Ende ist ich muss dann ja
noch drauf halten ich muss die Leute ja
Filmen dann noch wie sie reagieren das
hatte der dann doch mitgekriegt kam aus
einem Kiosk raus hat gesagt Kamera weg
oder ich bring dich um und das hat er
ernst gesagt und laut und laut der hat
hier richtig die Adern am Hals das war
ein IR das war ein Irrer und können wir
das sehen in der Staffel nee das heute
wirklich nicht das ist kein lustiger
Clip das schade der hat der den Clip
vorher schon versaut gehabt ne hinten
gerannt und wirkt und
so die Leute geben ja dann auch nicht
okay wir fragen ja immer ob das in
Ordnung ist natürlich K ne es wäre schön
wenn die dann doch am Ende Okay geben
würden und dann macht ihr eine Bad off
die
überhaupt ein Uhr Nacht wir wollen nicht
sagen wo wurde ich auch geschupst
letztes Jahr nein ja schlimm geschupst
war so ein Clip mit vielen Statisten die
papaazzi gespielt haben wir sind dann in
diverse Läden
rein nein nein nein
nein ne nein das fühlt sich auch keiner
keine Ahnung keine Angst keine Details
jedenfalls sind diese Paparazzi dann
wieder verschwunden nachdem sie die
Besitzer von diversen len fotografiert
haben und ich blieb natürlich als
letztes da weil ich habe ja dann wieder
die Reaktion gefilmt das heißt das ist
viel schlimmer dann kam so ein
Muskelmann auf mich zu und hat mich
richtig so weggekickt dass ich fast auf
die Fresse geflogen wä richtig auf die
Fresse mit Kamera und allem drum herum
wir sagen keinen Namen wir sagen nicht
wo es war es gab ein riesenbohi und
natürlich wird auch das nicht gesendet
weil im Endeffekt nicht gut das heißt
die die er dir BRT er dir ein und du
musst auslfen im weil du immer raus bist
weg ja es ist tatsächlich komischerweise
so schie glaub mal jetzt nicht so ich
das ist die meist gestellte Frage an
mich hast du schon mal aufs Maul
bekommen habe ich nicht
ich wüsste aber wie ich auf ma kriegen
würde muss man halt die falschen Leute
fragen aber der kameramanno ist schon
ein bisschen blitzaableiter nun ich weiß
nicht wie weit heutzutage jeder schon
mal von der Kamera stand wenn ein Typ
der ein nicht wohlgesonnen ist einem
filmt das ist ein unangenehmes Gefühl ne
wenn man nicht gefilmt werden will und
man wird trotzdem gefilmt und dann
entstehen so diese Aggressionen und dann
dann sieht man die Linse und dann
schlägt es um so irgendwie jetzt
umständlich formuliert also das ist das
Ding ne die Linse ist dann irgendwie
noch so da und stellt dich blo und dann
wirst du irgendwie
irre trotzdem war das Arschlöcher okay
ne euer Mikrofon ich aber ist es eiglich
euch schon mal passiert seid ihr schon
mal verarscht war von Kollegen
eigentlich seid ja dankbar und wie ist
das dann wenn ihr ver schon mal ein zu
ein ver ich bin ich bin hier in Köln da
stand ich hinter so Typen saß ich in
meinem Auto und dann sind die bei Grün
nicht losgefahren und ich bin voll Agro
geworden warum fte nicht los dann habe
ich gesehen wie der in Rückspiegel
geguckt hat und mich einfach ausgelacht
hat und dann weggefahren ist ja das war
sagen muss Leute woll die haben mich
erkannt ach so entschuldige ich bin
nicht so schlecht ich bin so schlecht im
Geschichten erzählen also die haben mich
erkannt und hab mich verarscht schön und
ich war wirklich auch sauer ich meine
wenn grün ist und der fährt nicht ich
war voll sauer und die Typen habe ich
irgwn gesehen wie sie nur gelacht haben
und da muss ich auch lachen das war
irgendwie gut hin und wieder versucht
mal einer bei dir ne aber man muss sagen
dass es tatsächlich nicht immer lustig
ist und das nicht weil man selber
verarscht wird sondern wir machen uns ja
lange Gedanken oder nicht ich aber Simon
und Jens ja dass ein Gag auch gut ist
ich versuche den dann umzusetzen sagen
wir mal mit der Kamera das sieht
chungelig aus aber es ist manchmal gar
nicht so einfach das so zu
koreografieren dass es dann witzig ist
und manche Leute meinen dann sie werden
auch noch lustiger als man selber und
schwierig da habe ich natürlich nicht
drunter zu leiden ich habe unter
Aggression zu leiden Simon unter
schlechten Witzen das heiß
schim wenn die die Situation erkennen
und mitspielen wollen oh das ist ich
glaub das ist das Untergang das ist dann
immer ein rohkpierer das das geht
einfach nicht das funktioniert nicht ne
daran erinner mich wir hatten einmal in
Dortmund eine Situation aufgebaut da war
ein
Pornodreh rechts vom Weg das Team links
das Pärchen was so ein bisschen
rumgemacht hat und dann sollten Leute
durch die Mitte gehen und dann hatten
die das wohl auch spitz gekriegt ich
habe keine Ahnung oder hatten mich
gesehen und dann
jedenfalls ist er dann die Treppe runter
hat dann auf das Team geguckt und so
und ich habe so
gedacht okay und war das gut so und wir
so genau danke dann warten wir mal dann
warten wir mal bis wieder irgendwi
zufällig einer hier noch ein anderer
vorbeikommt der uns nicht bemerkt
gutin Schauspiel nein das ist schön so
noch mal zur
DVD das ist eure Vorgeschichte kommt ihr
denn wollt ihr sowas noch mal machen
oder ist die dieses Kapitel eures Lebens
beendet das ist eigentlich nicht richtig
beendet wir haben einfach keine Zeit
mehr gehabt und viel davon wurde in
güterslow gedreht und war dem Umstand
geschuldet dass wir alle damals da
gewohnt haben nicht nur wir sondern auch
Alex Kark und wolle butzlav die ganze
Truppe die immer um uns rum war der der
der Alexander der wohnt auch in Köln und
der Wolle der wohnt noch in gütersl also
die haben so normale Jobs sind jetzt
nicht nicht in nicht in den Medien
geendet
nee ja es war damals die Zeit wir
wohnten alle im selben Kaff hat nichts
zu tun und sontags nachmittags einfach
die Filme
gedreht also haben ein bisschen was
kreatives gemacht alle hatten Spaß und
wir würden das wahrscheinlich immer noch
machen wenn wir da jetzt noch wohnen
würden wir haben jetzt allerdings uns
überlegt wir müssen das jetzt dann mal
planen also wir haben eigentlich Lust
mal wieder einen zu machen wir werden
einen neuen brennpun nehus Film drehen
tatsächlich und den gibt's ja auch bei
bei youtube klicksum ist do auch bei
Youtube das ist doch alles das ist do
alles n dabei 1 und 2 gibt's bei Youtube
aber den dritten noch nicht den
drittench mit dem dritten müssen wir mal
gucken was wir mit dem machen aber
brennpunk neverha ist auch der der lief
darauf und runter irgendwie der hatte
hatte viel kcks Klicks und da wird auf
jeden Fall neuer kommen mal sehen was
wir mit dem machen super alles aber
zusammen übrigens was mir noch
eingefallen was was ich lustig finde ist
ihr sagt ihr haben das aus Langeweile
gemacht das sagen auch viele andere
white Titi riesen Erfolg auf Youtube wir
hab auch gesagt wohnen in hilpolstein
das ist so ähnlich glaube ich ich hab da
jetzt am Wochenende zum ersten mal von
gehört und die haben auch haben
angefangen wir hatten nichts zu tun wir
haben uns gelangweilt hey und heute ist
halt noch einfacher ich weiß nicht was
habt ihr damals für Equipment gedreht
eiglich was gab's damal ja genau das war
aber das ging schon das ging schon
Moment so Homestory Filme von den
Finalisten von secret Talents das ist so
eine praktisch so eine Youtube Show wo
Talente entdeckt werden von Joko und KAS
moderiert und ich fahre dahin und dre so
homestories mit übrigens verleung am 9
juni riesen Event dann ist es halt okay
du fährst rum und machst diese
homestories in ganz Deutschland dann
dachte ich geil ich komme nach Hamburg
Berlin München bin ich aber nicht
sondern nach eichach nach
Offenhausen nach Korb und das sind echt
wunderschöne Städte es war wirklich ein
Erlebnis aber es waren alle so kffer
genau diese Leute wohnen wie wir damals
kein Unterschied kein Unterschied genau
diese Mittelklasse Kids die praktisch
auf dem Dorf sind die keine Discos haben
die sich kreativ dann selber
beschäftigen und was auf Beine stellen
und das hat mich total daran erinnert
das ist exakt genau dieselbe Liga ja
super ja das ist genau in in Hamburg
weiß ich nicht ich me was passiert in
Hamburg oder passiert was in Hamburg und
München und Berlin ganz bestimmt nein
aber das ist wirklich dieser Druck das
heißt man muss euch eigentlich wünschen
zieht wieder nach nearhorst und dann
werdet ihr in dieser Form mit Trash
Filmen wieder produktiv ja sollten wir
sollten wir kommt auch wie gesagt einer
kommt dieses Jahr definitiv okay da
freue ich mich dann gibt wieder eine DVD
von dem einen
bestimmt okay vi 5 Minuten Film und
Doppel DVD genau genau super vielen
Dank